hey guys said Ford here with another GS
news update
Xbox boss Marc Whitten has left his job
at Microsoft and will become an
executive at Sano's Microsoft veteran
Marc Whitten who worked as chief product
officer and corporate vice president for
the Xbox team is leaving Microsoft to
join Sonos also as its chief product
officer the news was announced today on
the Xbox wire I have had the extreme
pleasure over the last fourteen years to
work on the greatest product with the
greatest team and for the greatest
community Witten said in statement Xbox
is so special because of the amazing
team I've had the opportunity to work
with and because our fans are the most
incredible fans on the planet it has
been the highlight of my career to work
on a product so loved it's incredibly
tough to leave but I'm confident the
best days are ahead for Xbox fans in the
capable hands of a very talented team
Witten's decision to exit Microsoft will
not affect the remainder of the Xbox
leadership team though as going forward
these staffers will report to executive
vice president Terry Myerson who
oversees all windows windows phone and
Xbox software platform development so
will you miss mark Witten have you ever
heard of Marc Whitten bring you
picturing mark wahlberg let us know in
the comments and for all other xbox news
keep your eyes fixed right here at
Gamescom